[Music]
publican National Convention as I said
finally finally underway in Tampa
Florida and we decided let's get in on
this we sent a correspondent to cover
this incredibly important event we sent
one of our writers Deon Cole
we talked to Deon on yesterday's show
but he wasn't able to do much reporting
true story because our camera crew
didn't make it into Tampa yeah because
of the crazy weather got stuck halfway
there they got stuck halfway their
flight into Tampa was canceled and Deon
was there alone the camera crew finally
arrived late last night and Deon has
been out and around since then so let's
check in with him right now CEO is doing
live via videoconferencing the latest
technology please welcome Deon called
Deon I'm doing great Dion's good to see
it looks at you really are there how is
it going in Florida right now all this
great man is humid real humid it's a lot
of white people I mean I stand out here
like a black man in your audience
that's not funny Deon how is it going at
the convention that's what we sent you
there for what's going on have you been
on the floor of the convention oh I got
kicked out are you being serious did you
really get kicked out
yeah man late last night I was like
jonesing right now went to the
convention center and let me tell you me
being the comedian when I see big stages
and big microphones I got to get a piece
coming and so well this is what happened
look man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello white people how are you I haven't
seen these many white people since I
went to emit evil fair in Orange County
thank you so much for your time and I
appreciate you come out please
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry is that what got you kicked
out for real you see the guy with the
blurry face that was Secret Service
that's the hata of my metier you I gave
him a material a fair one Joe look at
him we sent you there to cover the
convention and you pull a stunt like
that the first night you're there I'm
telling you man when I see microphones I
lose my mind calling it plus I'm trying
to impress these women down there Davis
looking really nice okay so what are you
gonna do you've been kicked out for the
next two days in Tampa what's your plan
well it's nice weather down here and I
still got this team cocoa credit card
also us a bunch of drunk rich white
women who think I'm the Old Spice guy so
let's check with you back tomorrow
Dioner I try and get inside okay try and
get inside Dion call everybody
you